I love this film so much right you're
way too talented no thank you
I loved every minute of it hard-hitting
question if you had to pick him out in
John's song to sing at karaoke which one
would you pick
no I don't know my karaoke song is
actually faith by George Michael if I
were to do a nelson one it depends on
them on the vibe I say yes nay it
depends on the mood of the room like if
you really want to get people up on
their feet
sadly nice right for fighting a face
that's nice Elton has said that his
songs aren't easy to sing what would you
say was the most challenging either
sequence in the film or song that you
just really I mean you nail every single
one of them but which one did you really
feel like you had to work for I think
although it's a song that I feel
relatively comfortable singing I think
the cultural significance of your song
and since in our movie we use it to
depict the right thing of it I think
that felt like quite an important piece
of storytelling and you know I was
acutely aware that they had the scope to
become a sort of fairly maybe a bit of
historic a bit of a stoic bit of cinema
because it's such an iconic moment in
Bernie's history so I was very keen that
that had a magic to it and Dexter and I
talked at length about how we were going
to do it and and I was always insisted
that I sing that one life on set and I
think it's worked out quite well
it was one of the most emotional moments
of the film especially for the audience
thank you obviously that song has
significance for you as well being that
you sang your song yeah this whole
experience feel full circle to you yeah
of course I'm not I don't you know I'm
not a real believer in it's not really
but I do it's a nice idea particularly
you know with the romance of this
project because it's a celebration of a
great man and a great life so I'm happy
to indulge in it on this occasion I'd
say it's fated Elton you know give you
free reign in terms of talking to you
openly about his past what is that like
for you when you're portraying somebody
as as amazing as Elton but also given
the rain to interpret his songs and
history in your own way
it's a staggering compliment you know
and and that's exactly how I thought of
it I think you know Elton's been hearing
his songs covered for decades and so I
you know I don't know he's interest he
wasn't interested in hearing them be
done in the way he did them all those
years ago you know it's it's fun to hear
things reimagined and interpreted
because everyone can bring their own
spin on things and that's what we've
tried to do it's me
Dexter Giles everybody else's
interpretation of Elton and his story in
the hope that people will connect with
it why do you think he's such an
important icon for a whole number of
reasons I think his philanthropy is a
big part of it in the latter part of his
life I think the fact that he's a genius
and he is able to make these incredible
words written by Bernie Taupin
make personal experience Universal I
think the fact that he was such a
pioneer of of expressing yourself in a
totally unique way onstage and I think
the fact that you know his songs are the
soundtrack to so many people's lives
that's on the film Thank You wonderful
has your family seen it yet this working
can
you